okay so I finalized my business taxes
over the weekend and then my personal
taxes and I got a much bigger refund
than I did last year of course the
refund size doesn't really matter
because your withholdings can change
what matters is your effective tax rate
my effective tax rate is way down okay
my effective federal tax rate for the
2017 tax year was 26.2 percent my
effective tax rate for the 2018 tax year
which I just filed is only twenty two
point nine percent my tax rate effective
has dropped on the basis of the donald
trump tax plan by about 13 percent this
is a really big tax cut that i got now
what did i do to earn that tax cut
nothing I didn't do anything the david
pakman show grew in 2018 not in
significantly and yet my effective tax
rate went down by almost 13% now the
reasons why this happened it's a
combination of some deductions that are
available to businesses that are
structured with paths through income
combined with some changes to the
brackets and the code and other
deductions the specifics don't really
matter but the point is the david pakman
show grew in 2018 my effective tax rate
dropped 13% I got an actual real
significant tax cut so let's ask the
question is this good for the economy
let's explore that because the right
says it's good to give tax cuts to
businesses because they will produce
more they will hire more people and it's
going to be a big big win for everybody
it's just not true I mean it's just not
true my effective tax rate dropped from
26 to 22 percent am I gonna go hire more
people now of course not I hire people
based on demand I hire people on the
basis of whether I have work for them to
do but here's the really important thing
if I can take profits at 22% instead of
at 26% tax
I am incentivized not to invest in my
business okay this is like just a Keith
to understand I talked about this with
Dave Rubin when he was on the show and
it wasn't clear that he understood it if
I can earn profit and pay twenty six
percent or earn profit and pay twenty
two percent what do I choose I choose
twenty two percent the lower effective
tax rate is an incentive for me not to
invest in the business remember if I
invest in the business I lower the
adjusted income that saves me more if
the tax rate is higher I am more
incentivized to reinvest in my business
if there is a higher effective tax rate
it's just a fundamental backwards
element of the entire right wing view
around taxation this year I paid
thirteen percent less on the profit that
the business earned it's an incentive
not to reinvest there's no economically
defensible reason for my tax rate to
have dropped thirteen percent despite
the fact that the david pakman show grew
and this applies to so many of the
businesses that we are told if we just
cut their taxes it's gonna be great for
the economy it's going to be good for
everybody it's going to lead to hiring
it's gonna pump money into the economy
it's not I wasn't planning on that tax
return I am NOT spending on the
assumption that I am getting that tax
refund not return and it's simply not
better for the economy now you might say
David well then just send in more money
to the federal government that's not tax
policy me choosing to pay twenty six
percent instead of twenty two percent
that's not policy that's not money that
the government has budgeted for it's not
money that would be used in any
productive way when it's not actually
expected to be tax revenues on the basis
of a broader tax plan me sending in more
money is is just one of those ridiculous
right-wing sort of libertarian ish
cartoonish ideas doesn't make sense but
case in point why these tax cuts for
corporations are not good for the
economy